[Music]
all right let's go to matt in fort wayne
indiana hey matt how are you
i'm doing okay about you great what's
going on
all right thanks for taking my
call so i
i'm a high school personal finance
teacher and i actually teach um your you
know dave ramsey program
for teenagers
and uh you know
you know
what i'm trying to ask is um you know i
don't just tell them that i'm just
teaching you to teach this i actually
tell them i do live this i try to you
know i try to do the steps just like i'm
trying to encourage them to do
one of the things that i noticed and you
know i try to bring in you know stories
from my life we do the videos we do the
worksheets you know like i'm trying to i
can see it on their faces sometimes i
think they think some of this is just
a hoax you know
they just don't care matt go ahead and
say it they just don't care
yeah that was your life where you
screwed up and you made mistakes or that
was dave's life i'm so and so
you know so how do i
how do i break through that wall you
know if you get what i'm saying so do
they think they have it all together
like i don't need this stuff this isn't
important i think some of it i really do
believe some of them think this is you
know they got it all together that this
is the host and i try to tell them the
folks that think that they have it all
together the ones that are going to come
apart first
well here's the thing
here's what's interesting matt a couple
things um i'll say and then i'll let
george jump in here but the i spoke to
high school students on money
for about six years before ever was
doing business coaching or life coaching
any of the stuff that i'm doing now and
one of the things that is so difficult
and you know this better than anybody
because you're on the front lines is it
is so hard to make a high school student
care about something they just don't
care about
specifically it's hard to make them care
about a topic that they feel
is not relevant to them right now so you
can talk all day about being on a budget
but if they've got the 24-hour atm of
mom and dad
they're not really motivated to give
every dollar a name because they just
ask mom for a 20. can i have a 20 can i
have a 20. so part of it is you have an
uphill battle in the fact that you're
teaching them something that either is
not reinforced at home or is just not
even it's just not even a conversation
at home so the one thing i would say
just to kick this off as we dig into
this with you is any time you can have a
conversation with the parents at
parent-teacher conferences tell them
what you're talking about ask the
students to go home and ask the parents
do you have any debt how do you feel
about debt begin to involve the parents
and almost come alongside them and say
hey let's together help set them up for
success and some may be resistant some
may have some shame of their own money
mistakes but until you get the parents
on board it's going to be harder to
break through because there's not a real
uh consequence reward or even motivation
the other thing i would just encourage
you is
and i'm definitely a product of this of
being a high school student but you are
planting seeds that you may not see
grow even by the time they graduate but
you have no idea what that's going to
turn into and how it is sticking with
them so i just want to encourage you
even if you don't see a huge
transformation right now
in the back of their mind that these
conversations these lessons might come
to mind when they're offered a credit
card in college and they make a
different decision we we heard a really
cool story from a young man that um was
on the fence of which college to go to
one he was thinking about taking out a
ton of student loans because it was his
quote unquote dream school and another
one he could pay cash and work his way
through and he ended up paying cash
working his way through he's completely
debt-free making an incredible income
and he attributes that to our
foundations and personal finance course
so even if you're not seeing light bulbs
go off that doesn't mean you're not
planting seeds that will come into play
later but it's hard george this is a
hard audience to teach because they're
just they just high schoolers i'm not
i'm not usually scared on stage high
schoolers they put the fear of god in me
they're just sitting there with their
arms crossed right they're sitting back
and they're like they look like they're
actually asleep like you're not cool i
see right through your soul you're a
loser i'm like oh my gosh i guess i'm a
loser and so here's what i found high
schoolers middle schoolers they're
they're insecure and they're they're
playing it off with this kind of false
confidence like they're too cool for
everything and so what i found because i
actually hosted the latest edition of
our foundations and personal finance
curriculum and as i'm writing these
scripts i'm like how do i connect with a
16 year old like what would 16 year old
george want to see on the screen and i
realized i just need to own my mistakes
and be self-deprecating connect with
them where they're at and talk about
their goals not talk about me and why
it's important to invest in the power of
compound interest i want to get their
vision for what they want for their life
and usually when you get them talking
about themselves then they're bought in
to why it connects to what you're trying
to teach in the personal finance so
matt i love what you're doing i already
love teachers in general sure but
especially the ones that are teaching
personal finance and even more so the
ones that teach our personal finance
curriculum and so i don't know the way
what your class is like they may love
you already
but get them to talk about their dreams
and their goals and what i found is it
is like an interrogation when you ask
them about college they say what do you
want to do how much is that going to
cost do you know how much that is a
semester do you know how much books are
how much student loan debt are you
willing to take on and you start to ask
these questions and they get all frozen
like oh my gosh i need to learn some
things i gotta google some stuff i gotta
talk to mom and dad and like you said
christy they're not having these
conversations at home so matt you are an
especially important part of their lives
and so you can pour into them even more
so than some other parents who are maybe
unwilling to have these conversations
don't agree with the ramsey principles
because they're drowning in debt and
feel like it's normal
and so what i would do if i was you is
connect with them on their dreams and
their goals and get on their level and
don't talk at them talk with them and
once you do that it's going to be a
partnership where they're going hey
teacher how can i learn more about this
this is fascinating
it may just take some time but matt
you're doing awesome that's a hard job
and we commend you we are so grateful
for you doing that hard work on the
front lines and we really do believe
that that is going to pay off you're
planting seeds you may see it tomorrow
you may see it this year you may not but
i believe it's going to stick with them
in more ways than you know great job
thanks for calling